[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm
just checking in on you
how are you
how's your thursday going man
um
oh [ __ ] stupid me man
i was all clean i wasn't [ __ ] doing
anything then i go to vegas i started
eating like [ __ ] i smoke a cigar now i
gotta start all over again sound [ __ ]
believable
so
i'm back cleaned up
you know but it's good though because
usually when i [ __ ] up like that then it
takes me another three months to get the
momentum to be like all right no sir
guys
stay away from the coffee
don't eat any weed gummies
now it's just been more like four days
it's just like hard am i really gonna
[ __ ] do this i don't want to do this
all right let's get back to the gym
let's do the things we need to do
let's fill up the tie that we spent
hurting ourselves with different
activities that will build for a better
future
so i've been playing a lot of drums
instead of [ __ ] sitting around
smoking cigars right so
um
i sat down yesterday
and it finally [ __ ] happened i i was
able to play along to uh led zeppelin's
good times bad times one bass drum
playing those [ __ ] triplets now i
might go down there today
you know
giving a [ __ ] too much legs a little
tighter
foot or whatever and then it doesn't
[ __ ] happen but
it did happen yesterday it finally
happened ladies and gentlemen all the
ships are safe
my dad drumming
went to the next level i'm actually
jamming with some buddies of mine when i
go back to um
uh boston next month
well back east
the family back east i go back east and
um
want to get up to massachusetts a few
days before
the fenway gig
um
let me jam with uh a couple buddies of
mine from back in the high school days
and they pick you know some easy songs
or whatever
and one of them ac dc tnt
it's just some tricky [ __ ] in there
it's like yeah i can play that's easy
can play this one oh my god if you saw
this [ __ ] scentless dude i mean it is
it is uh
i don't think anything is
like
post 1985.
one of the songs i don't think i've
heard it since it came out
do you remember that song by kiss tears
of falling
oh
no
t is a folding
just sort of a throwaway
you know
it's one of those songs that it did well
on i remember on the countdown but like
it never really got much radio play
after
probably because it was a zillion songs
being put out by bands like that
back then and i have not heard that
[ __ ] song since then i was like holy
[ __ ]
all right
we'll check this one out man so anyway
i'm [ __ ] psyched
it finally happened
um i just been doing that um
triplet exercises those
triple licks triplet licks and not doing
the actual
playing the good times bad times thing
because i just felt like that just got
in my head
that was just this frustrating thing i'd
always get almost to the top of the hill
and then [ __ ] slide back down because
i'd get busy or whatever
so uh
yeah so that happened and then yesterday
i flew a robinson r44 for the first time
in like almost two years coming up on
two years at whole i didn't remember
anything i could remember how to start
it
um the main rotor turns the other way so
all your feet inputs were were the
opposite
um
i can't even explain how [ __ ] up that
is because the top half of your body is
the same and then the bottom half the
the inputs go differently
well you basically do sorry i'm
recording this literally right as i got
up
uh was hanging with the kids last night
did not record the podcast um
all it is is you're yeah you know
with the one i have my left foot follows
the collective
when i follow the robinson
which turns uh where's that
counterclockwise
i think
the collector follows the right foot so
when i picked it up you know i was just
like all right just pay attention to the
nose but i was still a little cockeyed
and i was a little high when i was
taxiing but other than that it was cool
i was actually uh
hanging out with some friends of mine
and it made me uh
you know i was thinking like ah man i
could have got one of these
it's a little four seater
but the main rotor blades are bigger and
it's faster it has a v6 engine
but uh i actually by the end of the
flight i was really happy i got the
cadbury you can't even compare the two
as far as just like safety
uh the avionics that's in the cadbury
it's a full glass cockpit and i get i
have all the i can just hit a button
that says traffic and i see anybody
who's
near me or whatever like that and and
this was going back to like the analog
[ __ ]
and i was just like
i don't like this
i don't i do not [ __ ] feel as safe
so um
i'm also uh
i'm getting rid of a bunch of [ __ ] like
i have too many guitars
and i only play like
like
three of them and even then i play drums
most of the time so i have these other
ones
that i'm going to be selling dean delray
is going to sell them for me
um three guitars
that i'm gonna sell and then i have
and then i have three
and i don't [ __ ] think i need any
more than that and then i can kind of
keep them all in the same place as
opposed to having guitar cases all over
the place like i'm [ __ ] keith
richards i got a little crazy
you know i was playing guitar i was
having fun i'm like well i want to get
this guitar i want to have that guitar i
don't have this guitar it's just like
then i had kids and then it's like i got
to hide these guitars the kids are going
to put their hands on they're going to
[ __ ] the guitars up and then they sit
out here
then my [ __ ] air conditioning brokes
and i'm like i can't [ __ ] have my you
know
because the air conditioner is busted i
gotta [ __ ] you know stick them in the
garage then they're in the [ __ ]
garage and this spider's ah [ __ ]
celeb
so that's what's happening um
and i got a bunch of [ __ ] people have
given to me over the years
you know on the road of which i'm
looking at right now and i just gonna
[ __ ] autograph the [ __ ] and next time
we have a uh a benefit
um
at all thanks comedy i'm just gonna
[ __ ]
donate all that stuff
and josh adam meyer show shimmy shimmy
yeah we give [ __ ] away i'm [ __ ]
getting rid of a bunch of stuff do you
know i'm still [ __ ] dealing with that
goddamn shop vac that i bought
so i ended up going down to home depot
to [ __ ] exchange it
for those of you who haven't listened to
the podcast i went down to get this
[ __ ] shop vac
you know
so i can keep my garage clean
i [ __ ] hate this [ __ ] coming out here
and there's all kinds of crap
there's just no seal under the doors
the garage door in the in the side door
right so
it gets [ __ ] all over the place here and
it [ __ ] drives me nuts i don't like
it i like i like a nice clean garage
that has cars in it
that's my [ __ ] a little podcast
studio that's what i like i [ __ ] hate
people who use their [ __ ] garage
as a storage unit
you know
or they just convert it to more s
square footage for their house they turn
the entire thing into some sort of man
cave or some [ __ ] i [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ]
you know
i don't i don't it's my stupid thing i
just look at it as like great now now
you have to have now you have to go buy
more [ __ ]
to decorate that now you need another
sofa
couch davenport whatever your age is
whatever the [ __ ] you call it
get your feet off the davenport
that was my grandfather
um
anyway um
that's just one of those things that
[ __ ] drives me at the wall you know
there's this movement on the internet
where people are annoyed by people that
back into parking spots
like this is the most egregious thing
you could ever [ __ ] do it's like it
isn't
it's a brilliant thing to do you back in
and you've clearly made your statement
that wherever you're about ready to go
you don't want to be there
or you want to get the [ __ ] out of there
you're putting that energy out to the
universe if it's a social situation
people see it it's fantastic
so i guess my version of that is if you
don't [ __ ] put your car in the garage
i think you're an [ __ ]
uh get your goddamn feet off of that
[ __ ] davenport he didn't talk like
that
davenport
those are all those words that went away
huh
davenport remember dungarees instead of
jeans
work boots boondockers
he had on his dungarees and boondockers
and christ he goes over and he puts him
right on the [ __ ] davenport
um are you from america
um
anyway uh oh i went to the all-star game
i heard they had every player [ __ ]
mic'd up too which is my dream scenario
in any sporting event
is that all the athletes are mic'd up
even if they're joking around it's cool
but i you know if they were actually
[ __ ] pissed at each other you can
hear what the what they're saying
talking all kinds of [ __ ]
um
you know but obviously you can't have
that because kids are watching and that
type of thing but i've always said that
you could have like an opposite channel
the r-rated channel
then you know what would happen if the
feed would accidentally go to the clean
channel
and someone would be arguing a call
saying every you know word the book
probably wouldn't be a good thing
what do you think bill
are you going to go on a limb right
there and say that that wouldn't be a
good thing yes i am
um
so we ended up going there and uh
i got hooked up with some tickets by bet
mg mgm hooked us up thank you for the
tickets
unfortunately it was hot as [ __ ]
balls
and where we were sitting
we were in the uh the upper deck the bob
euchre seats along the first space line
and
the way the sun goes down is that part
of the bleachers is facing west so the
sun is just in your [ __ ] face the
whole time so
uh
i went with like three other dudes right
so two of them went to go get the beer
and the food
me and my other buddy sit down
and we sit and we're literally
like one row in front of the shade but
the shade's going away anyway because
the sun's going down it's just basically
gonna
kill everybody in that section
and we were just sitting there for like
two seconds and he literally just looks
at me it's like you know you know we
could go down there and help help them
out with the food
because he's a nice guy he didn't want
to say these
these seats are going to be brutal and i
just started laughing
he's like no he's not fine he's fine we
got the car serviced he was already
talking about the car service before the
[ __ ] game even started so we ended up
going down
and um
i don't know because of the all-star
game there seemed to be very few ushers
working and we ended up finally finding
somebody
and figuring out
you know where the dodgers pro shop was
to buy some stuff i got uh the american
league all-star jersey for myself and
for my daughter
and uh i was standing in line i couldn't
find the one that said boston on it
and my buddy's like i'm thinking i need
a large we're really good my buddy was
like what do you want a meeting
medium and i said yeah
knowing that i needed a large probably
needed a large i held it up and i
thought it looked alright then i came
home and i mean i fit in it but it was a
tight jersey you can't walk around a
tight baseball jersey
you ever go to a hockey game when you
see some guy wearing a [ __ ] jersey
that used to hang like you know like you
could put pads underneath it now it's
like [ __ ] skin tight looks like he's
ready to go ride up
a [ __ ] time trial on a bicycle yeah i
can't have that so i'm gonna give it to
somebody else um
but anyway we ended up standing on the
sixth deck
looking down at uh
at the game and just cracking up and
having a good time and uh
this guy came up
and he saw me and then my buddy's an
actor right and he's [ __ ] looking at
us he's like oh my god what's going on i
like your comedy oh my god i love that
tv show or the movie that you did it
blah blah then he just looks as he
goes what are you guys doing way up here
[Music]
and all my friends just started [ __ ]
laughing at me because they were busting
my balls
about where we were sitting
um i didn't mind the seats i actually i
mean it just was the heat the seats were
fine so i'm not [ __ ] on bet mgm i
really appreciate the tickets and also
took me back the first time i ever went
to that stadium
was in the mid 90s i went to uh a night
game thank christ
and uh i remember it was right when mike
piazza you know he'd already just start
to make a name for himself that he was
you know the star of the dodgers and a
star across the league so that was
pretty [ __ ] cool
um
but anyway we ended up having a blast
and i i was talking to them the next day
they were like it was actually kind of
[ __ ] cool because we ended up walking
all around the stadium we just did
standing room just staying in the shade
and uh we were up by home plate we saw
kershaw come out
and uh
oh that ohtani kid
he called it he goes what are you
looking forward to most he goes first
pitch first swing and then he goes up
there against kershaw
first pitch he takes the first swing and
he just [ __ ] laser right up the
middle for a base hit
and we were like oh [ __ ]
did he say first swing first hit did he
said i was gonna you know we would take
another's like no no no he said uh
first pitch first swing something like
that
and uh we were all bummed that they
wouldn't let him pitch but um
anyway so then the next person kershaw
faced was aaron judge
so it's just like wow let's see what
happens here and uh he ends up doing
some veteran move
just getting ohtani leaning the wrong
way steps off the rubber over the first
[ __ ] picks him off and then strikes
out aaron judge you're like all right
that was [ __ ] sick
um
[Music]
i just wish i got to go back and watch
the game because i want to hear i want
to hear them be all miked up and then we
ended up later on we ended up all the
way out in uh
where did we go we went to uh we watched
along
the
third base line for a little bit then
the first space line and then we ended
up all the way out in the outfield
and that was a good time there's always
great people out there so uh
you know we ended up
we ended up out there
and uh there was a bunch of people from
the armed services were there
and we were talking about like the
sailors uniform that they have
how like broadway
shows have like ruined that uniform
where you see like the marine uniform
you know the army uniform you know the
dress whatever but like you see like the
navy one you just think five six seven
eight
[Music]
um
it's wrong
what they need they do is they need to
do another movie
because i gotta be honest with you out
of all the war movies that scare the
[ __ ] out of me the most
it's the navy ones
and that is the last
branch
that i would [ __ ] join there's no
[ __ ] way
i would join the navy because i don't
want to be on a ship that sinks and you
end up in the [ __ ] water
and now you're in quince [ __ ] story
from jaws
um
i know the odds of that now but you know
i talk to guys you know i meet people in
the armed services and i talk to these
guys in the [ __ ] navy they talk about
people falling overboard and not being
able to find them i just cannot
[ __ ] believe that
just the terror and the loneliness of
that death just sitting there in the
middle of the [ __ ] ocean they can't
find you they probably turn the [ __ ]
thing around to look for you you can see
them they can't see or hear you
and then you see when they quit
they [ __ ]
sail away or some [ __ ] you probably die
a hypothermia then god willing
god willing you die of [ __ ]
hypothermia
you're not just hanging there
for a [ __ ] shark to come along to
hell with that
um
then you got to think who really has a
good navy anymore
did you guys watch that cry of the wolf
the french movie
that was another one you know submarines
and all of that stuff my god
they got to run quietly and they're
waiting for the depth charge to go off
[ __ ] all of that man
[ __ ] all of that
if i joined the armed services
before i went in i would learn how to
build websites and that i would request
that duty
i can help with recruitment sir
um just don't have me in the [ __ ] sun
please for the love of god and i don't
want to be out on the water all right i
don't want to be on land or on water i
want to be in an office
those are my requirements for my service
to my country
um
oh speaking of that i have an idea man
i don't know why this hasn't been filled
yet
you know there's a restaurant called
hooters
okay and you know they sell food and
then the chicks walk around with like
titties some real some fake
kind of like their chicken right
it's mostly chicken
i have no idea what it is um i was
thinking like
you know nobody gives a [ __ ] about tits
anymore
people finally came around to what i
always knew it was always about the ass
right
so why don't you [ __ ]
have ass hooters
right you call it cakes
and you do the same thing it's like
mcdowell's but you just do it you have a
restaurant it's called cakes and it's
only only real asses
real ass [ __ ] need to apply no real
only real asses not the fake ones
you know where you walk and the ass
doesn't move none of that [ __ ] right
and you serve the same level of mediocre
chicken and then i think that you kind
of undercut hooters
you call it cakes
you know
and then just to keep the feminists
at bay
you actually have uh an array of cakes
that you can have for dessert
no it has nothing to do with us
exploiting uh
turning our wait staff into sex objects
it has to do with our dessert menu and
i'd appreciate it if you get your mind
out of the gutter and maybe take a look
at the menu first next time before you
come over here
and insult me and everybody else here
all the other fine people here over here
at cakes
hooters and cakes
it's like turks and caicos right except
the restaurant version of it
oh that's what you do you partner up
with the turkish restaurant chain if
there is such a thing
you call turks and cakes
oh
whatever i'm just brainstorming here
people but it would [ __ ] work i think
i think it would work
and then you could say how progressive
you were
because of all the minority hires that
you would have obviously if you were
trying to corner the market on asses
you know those would be a lot of
minority hires
[Music]
was it the fact that you were actually
woke or was it
just that's what the market was
when of those 60-minute interviews i
mean you're dodging everything you're
we're really supposed to believe you
that you called the restaurant cakes
because of your dessert menu i mean look
at this look at these photos look at
this there's not one woman facing the
camera and there you are you're twice
the age of everybody there
you know i don't think i like what
you're suggesting
suggesting i'm suggesting it sir
this is in your this is a picture on the
on the front cover of your menu at cakes
oh that was my wife's idea
um anyway sorry that was the the 60
minute saga of cakes
turks and caicos um
sorry
anyways major league baseball's coming
back
[ __ ] bummed out man
you know
why do they need to announce that the
red sox disorder this is a rebuilding
year
why'd they need to do that
i mean you could have waited till august
as long as you know you're running the
team so what the [ __ ] do i need to know
for can i just sit there and ignorant
bliss going like
maybe sales finger will
will heal jesus christ that [ __ ] guy
he's had everything but a piano fall on
him
um
oh it is what it is i'm still going to
watch him
just what else am i going to do it's
still
five and a half weeks dude let's look up
when does the nfl season start
this is this is the question that you
asked when the owner of your team says
that it's now a rebuilding year
um
i'm still gonna ride with them through
the dog days of august man uh
let's see oh what about the houston
astros just getting mercilessly booed at
the all-star game
jesus christ
i thought dodger fans had a lot of
[ __ ] balls booing the houston astros
you know okay they went to home depot
they bought a trash can what did you
guys do you went around the league and
bought every [ __ ] star in the
universe and have close to a 300 million
payroll
come on what are we doing here
people on the dodgers tested positive
for [ __ ] steroids too we're we're all
doing something
let's not just pick on houston
because they're consistently voted one
of the fattest cities in the united
states you know
[Music]
and you feel a little extra confident
because you know they can't catch you
carrying all that weight i'll tell you
what would do great down in houston a
little restaurant called cakes
huh
oh my god that'd be hard to [ __ ] hire
women down there
i thought it was called cakes yeah but
it's like an in shape
you know we want n-shaped booties now
you just have a fat ass okay there's a
difference
i'm gonna report you to the restaurant
better business bureau okay you do that
you do that and we'll get him drunk here
we'll get him some dessert and have a
few these chicks sit in his lap and that
whole problem's going to go away because
this is texas man
all right you can still do [ __ ] like
that i'm [ __ ] with you all right
sorry i'm looking this up
nfl
first
first game it is
thursday september 8th [ __ ]
all right
let's let's change the question
excuse them off
ah you [ __ ] content i swear to god
what is with this search thing where the
whole thing then just selects
what's the deal
with every not mlb you idiot
a a
don't they start a week earlier
search
what we got what we got
what we got
can't they do i don't
hey robot in my phone
what's the uh first what's the date of
the first ncaa football game this year
saturday august 27th
all right in today's what the 21st
yeah
we're only about five weeks out
whoa and did i hear that they realigned
is that something that i heard
that ucla and usc are not in the pac-10
anymore
let me see this
maybe yeah i should do this voice thing
huh right
hello robot person this is your owner
bill burr
i want to learn about ncaa realignment
this is the [ __ ] worst question ever
i'm not sure i understand
i'm right there with you buddy
ncaa realignment
what's the deal
i like to challenge it
devon deal
deal from which team all right
ncaa realignment
which sport football you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh the little pie thing's spinning
all it's doing is just giving me
schedules
what the [ __ ] that florida team with
the goddamn prehistoric snake on the
side of its helmet
that's not okay
i don't know i don't know what i don't
know what you just said this doesn't
help me
anyway i just know i got
a text from somebody to go well
kiss the pat ten pac-12 goodbye
and i was like what does that mean
it's like [ __ ] realignment
is it a good thing is it a bad thing i
don't know
all right we have a read here everyone
uh helix
pelix
you know sleep is important everything
from your immune system to your
metabolism make sure you're getting the
best night's sleep you can helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete and matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you sleep everybody's unique
and helix knows that's knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses just like the
tires
in racing
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot you sweaty bastard
masters mattresses mattresses
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains
mattresses for people who sleep on their
stomach and wake up with morning wood
mattresses for people who shut the bed
sorry
um
helix is awesome
but you know you don't need to take my
word for it
he bulletproof mattresses
for liberals who don't have a gun in a
house
um it was awarded the number one overall
mattress pick of 2020
uh by gq and wired magazine
so amazing that they have a magazine
about doing blow
helix was has been recommended by
multiple leading chiropractor doctors of
sleep medicine as a go-to
solution solution solution for improving
sleep
just go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute quit sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress
mattresses for people that take mattress
quizzes
that will keep give you the best sleep
of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free
do things you do i'll take things i do
on a mattress for five hundred
uh well i just did the hacky [ __ ] 80s
joke structure uh they'll even pick it
up for you if you don't love it gross
but you will
helix even has financing options and
flexible payment ladies
uh plans
so a great night's sleep is never far
away helix is offering up to 200 dollars
off all mattresses
or mattress orders and two free pillows
all right
we got pillows for people who like to
put it on their head
we got pills for people that over
between their knees
this read is like the the helix lead
they're gonna do after the nuclear
warhead lands and they're just [ __ ]
stuck in a loop of what they were doing
right before it land landed um and two
free pillars for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helix
sleep.com h-e-l-i-x-sleep.com
b-u-r-r for up to 200
off all mattresses and two free pillows
there you go
sleep your afternoon away all right
that's it that's perfect man 7 30 a.m my
kids are just getting up my son
can now uh escape the sleep sack
and um
and for those you who are my age and
your kids are all grown if you don't
know what a sleep sack is i don't know
when they were invented it's sort of
like a workout vest for a toddler
except you're not doing it so they can
work out you're doing it so they you
know
have difficulties getting out of the uh
their bed
so my son is all muscle and he just
pulls himself up and he goes right up
and over like tom cruise figuring out
some [ __ ] in the beginning of one of
those mission impossible movies
and now he just comes walking into our
bedroom it's so funny you just hear his
little hand and he opens it up the door
he comes walking and he just goes
hi
and then we're up so
now i have to surround
his bed with like pillows because you
know
i just it's one of those deals if we
just had him in a regular bed he'd get
out immediately so you got to have an
obstacle so now he has to climb up and
over this [ __ ] thing but i still want
him to fall down and get hurt because
his sister did that and ended up with
like literally a cartoon level knot on
her head
um
you know it's terrifying to me so i just
put pillows all around it speaking of
which this is freaking me out i have to
go check it i have to go check in on
them uh this is the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast enjoy
enjoy the uh
the music picked up by andrew themless
then we'll have a bonus episode of the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast to follow all
right
half hour episode bonus to come that's
it
go red sox i'm still hanging in there
with them um and thanks to bet mgm for
getting us into the game i've now been
to the all-star game in all four sports
i actually forgot i went to the nhl
all-star game
um what's his face uh
joe bartnick reminded me all right i'm
gonna stop talking now see if i can find
where's the arrow where's the arrow okay
clicking
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
uh this is a very special
edition of the monday morning podcast
you know every once in a while here on
the podcast rather than listening to my
psycho ramblings and my jam jams as i
lay on my bed every once in a while uh
i'll have a guest on of high esteem and
uh this episode
is of no exception this is a man i've
done a lot of radio with but i've never
had as a guest please welcome the one
the only the legendary from new jersey
mr jimmy norton thank you bill what's
going on it's funny it's like uh do you
i know you're such a solo guy when you
do your podcast i almost felt like when
i texted you to do it i almost felt like
i i you were the hardest one for me to
text i know you longer than i know any
of them right and it was you were the
hardest ones i'm like bill does it by
himself i don't want to put him on the
spot but you said you've had some guests
no no i've had grades i had jaymore i've
had okay
i've had dave kechter i've had uh
michael rappaport was great just the
whole sports thing that guy's like a
total like
hoop head now
yeah [ __ ] boston and all that so we had
a great going back and forth and of
course he trusts me for the giants being
the patriots so i try to get guests that
i'm friends with because i'm not
the greatest interviewer
and uh so i definitely you know someone
that i've done a bunch of radio with now
watch are we feeling the tension that
it's all gonna go off the rails no it's
funny it's one of those things though
whenever you're with a friend or whether
you're interviewing or talking to
somebody that you know as well as we
know each other it's all you almost feel
self-conscious like oh no they're going
to think i'm putting on my performer hat
or my interviewer hat or my radio guy
it's like oh jim tell us how did you get
your start no i know and that's what
comedy podcasts have turned into every
comic in colin won't do him he's like
i'm sick of tired talking about your
[ __ ] process you know he doesn't want
to hear no it's starting the process and
he's right i'm actually
i'm out of stories i kind of like
tapered back
on doing other podcasts not because i
don't like other podcasts i just i've
run out of stories
i don't know how many more like the
amount of times i tell a story and i
yeah i've probably told this one before
but uh
i mean you know everybody's got your
classic half dozen dozen stories unless
you're like a guy like jim jeffries and
you just live in like a classic story it
seems every three [ __ ] alcohol an
active alcoholic if you're an active
alcoholic and you always know he's nice
not that he's sober yeah yeah he's but
he's been he's been been a good boy for
a couple years
even if he isn't i'm not going to say
he's an active alcoholic i just got to
sit there and be like you know he likes
having a good time that jim jefferson
he came in one time and he was i think
still gone from the night before it was
quite enjoyable i like i don't drink
anymore but i love a guy who's drunk
like on the air oh yeah awful to deal
with in real life both in the air put a
microphone in the front it's great radio
god they're great he brought in who's
that big irish community andrew
something something he's one of the
biggest ones he does arenas in ireland
oh okay he met on st paddy's day and he
was [ __ ] loaded not not tommy turning
no no we've had him too okay he was the
sober this guy i think is bigger than
tommy and uh he was just so drunk and
obnoxious it was just funny to watch
this guy who in his home country is you
know he's like kevin hart right uh just
loaded and [ __ ] seven o'clock in the
morning blathering making no sense i'm
like
who you are thank god i don't drink
anymore no they don't they don't [ __ ]
around over there like it is a uh
it's a whole other but i mean there's
definitely it's not like everybody over
there is a drunk right but like there
isn't like that
i i i'm saying this is a tourist i just
didn't see the level of concern
where everybody's so worried about
everybody over here like do you think he
has a i'm really concerned about so and
so like i didn't feel that vibe over
there it was more like um if you felt
you had a problem
maybe you tried to go to a an i don't
know if they have aaa over there is that
yeah is that worldwide
has that spread
yeah it's made it everywhere russia has
it
no it doesn't does it oh yeah everywhere
has it
yeah that's what i've been told are
there youtube clips of just like people
saying it in all different languages you
know that's a good question i've never
looked from what i understand the
drinking is anonymous so people don't
state their
affiliation with it publicly just oh
that's right you wouldn't film it they
probably wouldn't allow that yeah they'd
probably frown on some guy with a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
how would you know i mean do people film
the anonymous meeting
this is the level this is the level of
of intellect that you're going to get on
this so so [ __ ] settle in there's
nothing wrong with that it's one of
those things where everything's online
anyway i mean everything is the fact
that the [ __ ] first tower getting hit
there's a a clip of that is hey i don't
have a windscreen on that so you're
popping on your keys a little bit so
that's that's my that's my fault sorry
my last one five days a week for 10
years and i don't know not to go into a
[ __ ] microphone i'm a true idiot
but the fact that that's why opi by the
way says but and not put he'll say uh
did you put that down like there's
certain words he says p is b
because he
he went to broadcasting school
danny that sounds like such a such a
broadcasting school thing college no
maybe in college he learned i think he
learned in college actually but you know
he went from communications but um
the fact that there is footage of the
first tower getting hit like that plane
going in and you know back then everyone
didn't have the cell phones with the
cameras as a miracle like so it's not
surprising that people think that things
are going to be filmed i don't know why
i'm on this agent but it's not
surprising to me okay i'm glad that was
a tangent because i was like trying to
adjust the level there as you adjust the
microphone away from me i was like oh my
god he's talking about 911 where the
hell did we go oh yeah just for a second
just i just thought of like a weird
thing to be on film just as a color yeah
just a little something just a little
something just to bring us back to how
lucky we are bill you know
how awkward would be if i just mentioned
9 11 and started blubbering
anything worse than somebody cries like
way too long oh by the way we're sitting
in in jim's [ __ ] fabulous hotel room
so that would really be [ __ ]
uncomfortable just creepy yeah on every
was as long as the mics are on and i
feel there's an audience even though i
can't see him yeah it wouldn't be that
bad but if if we were just here by
ourselves which [ __ ] takes me back to
a moment
cleveland that i yes
i was in a hotel room pissed
and you [ __ ] knocked on the door and
talked me off the [ __ ] ledge it was
it was the gig after the philly gig
where i was like
i knew that they were going to boo me
again just to boo me rather than philly
they booed me because they didn't like
me
and then um by the time the [ __ ]
cleveland gig you guys gave me so many
props that the crowd wanted to see it
again yeah so i was asking uh
somebody there hey just put me on early
give me a chance just give me a chance
to be like yeah yeah yeah don't worry
and then i was in the exact same spot i
go out there and i just walk out i'm on
for two seconds they just start booing
me
just to boom me and i was like look i'm
not gonna pretend to get mad because you
guys are pretending to boo me and it
didn't go anywhere i got off stage and i
was [ __ ] livid i remember me and jeff
will still laugh about it because jeff
was like no no i'm sorry i was like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] this and you [ __ ] this stay
[ __ ] everything and i left i think i
threw a water bottle yeah you were very
unhappy i was i was not happy and oh no
because me i catastrophize in my head so
i was like going oh my god i've become
the boom guy and i'm going to go any
everywhere i go i kind of forgot because
i had been on the virus tour long enough
that
um to me a normal show was [ __ ] 10
000 people right and i wasn't thinking
like my next gig after that tour was at
the punch line it's like a cozy right
200 people and i can see everyone
you know and so if anybody [ __ ] with
me i could get them and so anyways
so i go back to the [ __ ] hotel room
uh ready to quit the business and i hear
a knock on the door and you came walking
in and [ __ ] talked me off the ledge i
remember that i don't remember what we
spoke about i just remember you were
very upset and i knew why and you were
like they [ __ ] and i was like dude
they did it because they were trying to
recapture a moment that they wanted to
be a part of something that was very
amazing to them as opposed to they hated
you you know what i mean
and i was convinced everyone was out to
get me
the the crowd the show
uh uh they're not what the live nation
everybody i'm still convinced they're
about to [ __ ] me i couldn't do the
oddball tour this year i can't get on
the oddball tour and they're doing
[ __ ] the tweeter center and and
what's that you've played half of those
plays yeah and i can't get on the uh i
couldn't get a [ __ ] set on the
oddball
ah whatever they'll have it next year
yeah you know the [ __ ] is guys like you
and me we always gotta [ __ ]
we always gotta go the extra [ __ ]
whatever it is it was always remember
that when they were doing the half hours
on on uh on comedy central or or
whatever the [ __ ] there was it was
always the guy with the silly hat the
person with the catchphrase the hot
chick the fat guy
you know the black guy who doesn't scare
white people they had to get through all
of those
and then they also had to get the
veterans that they [ __ ] over on the
last group of half hours they have to
get rid of all of those [ __ ] guys
and then and then it was always us
afterwards i never did with comedy
central i was so resentful over being
passed over i was like fredo i just was
like [ __ ] these guys i'm not gonna do it
and then i wait i waited for you i'm
funny too yeah not like everybody says
yeah well that's the way doug wanted it
the way i wanted it yeah
so i wound up i said i want to hold out
for hbo and that we finally did them for
hbo and they were supposed to do four
and they were going to be really these
special half hours and now they want to
do in 10 of them and um you know i'm
happy we did it yeah i'm glad i held out
for hbo yeah you did and you did the
same year um
the same year that i did it well you oh
you want okay yeah it was i taped with
patrice you taped with kevin brennan
right i still remember that then louis
ck yep here's the thing here's the thing
one time um
you know because i'm obsessed with
trying to own everything i did
you know i tried to buy my half hour
back from hbo but they wanted me to buy
the whole i had to buy the whole [ __ ]
series i had to buy like all 10 of them
how much they want oh jesus it was like
you know
in the millions so it's just i mean i
was looking at like well it cost me 130
to shoot an hour so i ought to be able
to offer them [ __ ] 65 and they were
like no you have to buy the whole season
and like you know [ __ ] it i don't know
some
other thing to throw money at the
sopranos or something to get it but i i
wish i had the money because but
nowadays everyone just steals everything
anyway so it's probably dumb but when i
was looking back at that i'm like that
series is [ __ ] insane yeah that's you
patrice o'neill rest his soul was the
[ __ ] greatest i ever saw uh louis
earthquake it's friday flight of the
concourse was one of the conchords was
one that's right i forgot they were on
it they wanted me to do it with those
guys and i didn't want to i did one and
i was just like uh
you know i i think once what's his face
bought delirious off of them they were
shy they got a little gunshot oh he owns
it now murphy i didn't know that
no what's his face coming up next
comics unleashed that guy oh byron allen
byron allen bot that [ __ ]
delirious hbo showed that [ __ ] thing
and then they just when we were kids
teenagers
and uh
they just never showed it again they had
in their library and somehow byron allen
went in there and bought it off of him
how much right i don't know what he paid
for like a couple million bucks and
right before the whole dvd thing died
he put it out
at like 15 20 or whack and he sold like
four million of them or something yeah
he's a genius
he is and a lot of people don't really i
don't like talking about people's money
but this [ __ ] guy it's like this guy
he has like three quarters oprah money
and people don't even know yeah they
just look at him like he's one of those
guys like you know like
how seinfeld sees a show where everybody
else sees just hanging out right he's
one of those guys like i saw seinfeld on
uh um the daily show the other day
talking to jon stewart
and they were joking how he was saying
how he did tv right how he just did it
did it once it lives forever and jon
stewart when he does an episode of the
daily show it's it's all topical so no
one's going to buy the box out of the
[ __ ] daily show
and um and jesus i'm taking the long way
around here
so he was talking about the new tv show
he's doing uh on
on the net which is [ __ ] uh comedians
and cars getting coffee and he said
which is what i would be doing anyway
right so byron allen was a guy took
those press junkets when you were just
like what was it like to work with
steven spielberg talk about mel gibson
blah blah blah all that he actually saw
a show
and then that's where he came up with
that coming up next thing it was just
the [ __ ] press junkets
i know what's coming up next is that's
he would say coming up next jim norton
talking about the vice show that he's on
and blah blah and he turned that he
turned that into a [ __ ] tv show that
comics unleashed is genius it's
literally just and it's the worst setups
of all time it's it's just do your act
for for three minutes of the clip but
it's [ __ ] jeans and he produces the
whole thing he owns the whole [ __ ]
guy's a gene like he's like a hero of
mine as far as like the way he does like
this business yeah he's basically for
people uh from this is too uh
going too quick here he basically that
show if you don't watch it it's just
byron allen sitting there with three or
four other comics he already knows what
your bits are so you've already written
the whole [ __ ] show for him and all
he does is just say your setup like so
jim uh have you ever uh you ever lived
in a [ __ ] building in new york and
then you're like as a matter of fact i
have and the other comments on that
drive because nobody's calling each
other out like they're all like just
participating like it is a really a good
time we're having like how can three
comedians sit there and listen to a guy
do a bit off that setup and not want to
[ __ ] attack them well they can't do
that because then they get sued by tough
crowd yeah you know what i guess that's
what that that's what made a tough crowd
[ __ ] tough crowd was [ __ ] awesome
that has such a
such a cult following do you know
people's they ask me like just as much
for first just a longer time
like uh when chappelle show coming back
when's tough crowd coming back those two
shows had like uh
these die hard fans and i i still don't
um
i i don't understand what about colin
not getting that he got his own show and
he gave every comedian in new york a tv
credit yeah just about like i was trying
to i remember towards the the last uh
season of that i was trying to think of
somebody who hadn't been on it he got
everybody on that i think he did yeah
was bobby bobby wasn't a regular on it
but bobby was on it a couple of times um
bobby kelly yeah oh i thought he was on
it quite a bit no i don't think he was i
could be wrong about that i mean i think
an opinion i think he didn't do it being
anthony on naw he didn't do that till we
were on satellite so maybe he was on
tough crowd more than i thought right
but i remember him being talked about
warm up for it at one point he's like i
don't want to [ __ ] warm up there you
know man bobby so i think that uh
you know he gets a very short fuse so i
think that he was on a few times but i
didn't i don't think i ever did it with
him right they get mad at me too he got
mad at me because i don't even remember
that we went to vega i mean we went to
vegas together but not the actual
fight and he got very angry at me i'm
like yeah i'm like yeah that was your
right foot it's like [ __ ] dude i know i
was [ __ ] there with you i'm like oh
all right sorry
i can't make fun of anybody for having a
temper but he's another guy who he's
always had to go the extra [ __ ] 12
miles he's just one of those guys he
does got that short thing i remember one
time i was walking down the street with
him when he was talking you know we all
just start complaining about the
business so he was complaining about the
business and he was going to uh
he was going to help me with the
computer was great with the computer so
he was going to help me and as we were
walking i used to live around the corner
from him and i'm thinking well my
computer's up on the you know the
[ __ ] whatever the seventh floor and
he's on the ground floor and i'm
thinking in my head
let me go and get the computer and we'll
take it over to his house so as he's
telling like his you know [ __ ] 20th
story about this business
i said hey bob what if i what if can i
just go up and get that he just [ __ ]
snapped and he goes don't interrupt me
[ __ ]
[ __ ] screamed it
screamed it on ninth avenue in like
broad daylight and
dude like everybody [ __ ] you know people
looking and [ __ ] and i just looked at
him like
and the old me would have taken the bait
and i would have gotten to this big [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you fight i don't know if this
is the new me i just was not in i don't
know i just wasn't in a place where i
was mad or anything he so came out of
nowhere that i just kind of looked at
him i was like bob i thought we kind of
got past
doing this to each other and then he
kind of laughed and it was gone
which he's always been able to do as
much as that guy flips the [ __ ] out he's
able to bring it back down and be like
all right dude listen dude yeah he's not
a grudge holder necessarily yeah yeah
yeah yeah so he [ __ ] uh
that was like an instant bobby classic
don't interrupt me yeah that's what a
great line echoing
i just like how he said it like i worked
for him like i felt like you should have
been behind some big walnut desk
well is it maybe we could do this don't
interrupt me [ __ ]
i'm talking cause you [ __ ] this up it
makes me so happy that makes me so that
that's a [ __ ] bobby scream and i'm
really happy that that happened to
somebody other than me
he's a frightening guy when he [ __ ]
yells i hate to admit it but bobby's a
[ __ ] maniac
he does scare me i i would call him a
maniac but that's uh that's the old pot
and kettle there i'm out of my [ __ ]
mind dude like when i'm out here i i
literally had to make a rule about just
relaxing
when i drive
and one thing that helps is very
therapeutic for me is letting people go
right if you're really liking i i get
so frustrated with the quality of the
driving out here the inability
to [ __ ] make turns at a decent speed
and and do when they go buy [ __ ] out
here the second they pass it it's it
they don't even remember it they have no
there's no [ __ ] clue as for what's
behind you
like you know what they do out here that
[ __ ] drives me not you'll be sitting
behind some guy at a red light you know
and you're up on his bumper you know
like you're supposed to be nothing crazy
and as the light turns green he then
puts his left [ __ ] directional line
it's absolutely enraging and it's
self-centered and yeah it's it's it's
i'm with you is it wrong that i
fantasize about pushing him into traffic
and no it's wrong that you don't have
the moral courage to do it
that's totally i think that's totally
right and whenever you hear about
someone getting shot and killed for road
rage
everyone first goes oh my god that
maniac that shot that person and i
honest to god the first thing i think is
i'm glad like until i find out the guy
with the gun was the dick right who who
[ __ ] up first i love that you have to
find out that the guy with the gun was a
dick i know to find that until i find
out the guy with the gun overreacted a
little
but it's just there's something about
because people are so self-centered and
narcissistic when they drive it it's a
reflection of who they really are so
that's why we take it so [ __ ]
personally man like let you let people
go if the guy if if if a guy doesn't
wave thank you to me
that i don't do that cardinal
i go from like being this [ __ ] mother
teresa person i turn into the devil
it starts i try to stay calm as such
with a couple of reelies in my car i
just go really really really you're not
gonna [ __ ] these [ __ ] people out of
here i don't know what the [ __ ] i ever
move down here before i end up turning
into that just because some douche
dude do you see the look on their face
they're like please please please let me
go and you go to let them go and you
think like oh hey thumbs up something
nothing they immediately are just back
into their own uh
i don't know i find sometimes i wave
people out here and they look at me like
weird like what do you know me like
maybe you know i did move 2 500 miles
away from where i learned
you know societal rules so maybe uh but
you know you just think if you know
if you wave into another white guy i
mean we're pretty [ __ ] generic yeah
you know there's not a lot of depth to
the culture here there's there's no gang
signs i can see black guys get a little
freaked out watching which way your
fingers are
well plus east coast though is so
aggressive and i hate to do like you
know anything but out here maybe that
courtesy
like you know in boston or new york if
someone lets you cut in it's like hey
[ __ ] i did you a courtesy like
hey thank you for the courtesy yeah
you're a good [ __ ] dude you're welcome
you're welcome but here it's like well
that was just expected because they
might do that for each other more out
here it's not a big deal that's the only
way i can think of i was on the
pennsylvania turnpike one time driving a
gig and i know i'm popping all over
every i'm very self-conscious talking no
you're doing much
i don't have anybody to help us out with
this okay i was uh driving to a gig and
the guy cut into my lane i was doing
about 70. it was raining and he had a
trailer normal and i'm like i'm
hydroplaning you know that was the rear
wheel drive too with my mustang real
hunk of [ __ ] [ __ ] hydroplaning car
good call and i'm driving and and this
guy's coming into my lane and i
immediately your mind when you think
you're gonna die goes very quickly and
i'm like okay you gotta slam on the
brakes you're gonna have an accident hit
the wall like it tried to it's that
smart yeah slow yourself down side
swiping the wall
so i jam on the brake i hit the horn and
he veers out and we don't have the
accident so then i'm i'm not afraid i'm
in a rage at this [ __ ] guy right and
i pull up next to him and it's a it's a
you know a fat black dude like you know
a family mopey guy and i'm i'm ready to
really you know cleveland from family
guy
actually yes william stevenson
and uh he looks at me and he gives me
the like oops i [ __ ] up wave like oh
sorry and he gives me that
and every bit of anger drew you can't
because he he just owned up to it i'm
sorry i'm sorry yeah way back no problem
yeah that was it in a second my rage
was gone
you know what's funny i sometimes when
somebody acts on the rage even though i
know it's wrong
i sort of lived through
the the [ __ ] ecstasy that that must
be like do you remember when russell
crowe
threw the phone yes i said guy i just
can't imagine like when you're in a
hotel and you're not getting the
customer service you want on whatever it
is that the fact that you actually take
the machine that they won't help you
with and [ __ ] hurt somebody the
person who's not helping you you [ __ ]
hurt him with it yeah completely wrong
thing to do but i can't imagine i always
was wondering like when he's letting
that phone go just ah just [ __ ] all
that rage going at him i think it was it
was good for him was bad for the guy
behind the uh behind the counter behind
the counter was bad two people learned a
lesson that day russell crowe learned
not to do it the other guy probably
learned better [ __ ] customer service
next time because i remember when that
happened i was in the greenwich hotel in
uh which de niro owns and i i remember
like oh my god that's a really nice
place it's beautiful like he would stay
at a dive what a stupid comment but i
remember thinking the satisfaction it
must have felt when the phone hit the
guy like how good that must have felt to
throw that phone with that [ __ ]
and again he got in big trouble for that
but yeah that was a story that i do you
know how mad you are you you're you're
pulling the wires out of the wall
and that voice is still not going okay
what are you doing what are you doing
and then you wrap it up you leave your
hotel you're walking down the hall you
leave your room you get into the [ __ ]
elevator and your brain's still going
yeah throw it at him yeah throw it is
that what happened well i mean he he
went downstairs to the front i mean i
don't i was assuming he picked the phone
up off the desk and just threw it on him
oh i thought he was upstairs in his room
maybe he was but i thought that he i
didn't i didn't i thought he just picked
the phone up and threw it at the guy
that makes way more sense if i find out
that he actually wrapped the cord and
took the phone from downstairs that
makes me love him more i was i loved him
just for picking it up i probably [ __ ]
it up i [ __ ] up everything i don't know
do you know the other day i i actually
called the periodic chart i called it
the periodical
yeah but that's understandable i mean i
was on breaking bad
that's no excuse
it's like you're on if you're on a
western you call it a cowboy hat
how do you not [ __ ] know it shows you
the amount of [ __ ] research i did
dude sometimes on twitter when you get
trashed it's just so [ __ ] on the
money and i i i always read
people are just being mean to be mean
but when they call me out
for all this stupid [ __ ] it really uh it
makes being on twitter worth it yeah
cause other than hyping your shows it's
usually just a bunch of people giving
you [ __ ]
with half the [ __ ] information
pause on that um they [ __ ] and then
it just becomes like uh you know it just
becomes like why am i on this thing
because it'll literally put you in a bad
mood then every once in a while somebody
like that guy waving
you know in the car he just gives you
[ __ ] in the right way and it makes you
[ __ ] laugh you retweet they like to
retweet them and it just it becomes like
all right
i'm [ __ ] cool with twitter again i
have a piece of criticism somebody
bashed me one time but i actually have
it on my my desktop and i i've opened it
a few times and read it it was just
about like you know i used to love jim
but he
but the guy made some valid points as to
what i do wrong on the radio and uh
about how like and i felt like
constructive criticism yeah but he was
mad but i actually felt like yeah this
is actually coming from a guy who is a
fan and who just thinks i've been quite
a [ __ ] for a while and uh
you know what i i read it and it just
resonated with me like this guy is not
wrong i mean i don't like what he said
but like it's a very mature way of
handling criticism but yeah normally
it's it's much more like rageful i want
to find out who they are and you know i
get very very angry and uh this time it
just it just got me right i'm like i
know he's being honest yeah and he's
like ugh i have been doing that ugh it
feels exposing when some stranger just
notices your [ __ ] your weaknesses and
your crutches i've had a couple of
heckles like that
where they kind of put you in your place
and you got to be like you want to be
like what do you do for a living that
sucks but you have to be like i finally
learned at one point oh you know
something i actually learned about
hannah heckler's in a different way
watching you
i did down at caroline's it finally
clicked
i i learned through watching you you
don't have to chop all their heads off
sometimes they are ordering food
sometimes they're just repeating a uh a
punchline like i saw i forget what you
you
they were talking and you just kind of
said something what'd you say oh okay
and you kind of like
you actually asked them what they said i
think that that's what it was rather
than just assuming
that they were trashing you saying that
you sucked and because the amount of
times i kept having this recurring thing
where someone if anybody talked i was
convinced they were saying that i sucked
and they were making fun of how i looked
at whatever you know it's the first
eight nine years of my career and i
would chop their heads off and the
amount of times afterwards people would
come up to me at the end of shows going
i was just asking where the bathroom was
or i was actually saying i enjoyed your
act and blah blah blah blah and then i
felt like
i couldn't get out of it man i like i
was locked in this
you know get him get him get him get him
get him kind of vibe and then i was
watching you and i was it took me a
while to learn how to do that well i had
one too it's once in a while that will
happen at the seller because that's such
a loud small area where you'll say
something to say you'll hear somebody
talking and i can only see if it's
somebody ordering a drink and i leave it
alone um you know because there's a
small room but once in a while you'll
hear talking i've had a few people like
dif over the years go like what would
you say i just think i think you're
funny i'm enjoying you and then i just
kind of now then i repeat that i just
kind of get the audience to laugh at me
with it because it's like all right they
all know i was about to
attack the person yeah you know they all
know that this is an almost heckle so
did you always do that or is that
something i think i learned in a place
called uh arba john's which was a it's
where i first met arie spears back in
like 1991 when he was going mom would
bring him to open mics and he would do
these robocop impressions but he was too
young to get in by himself so his mother
took him and it was a a sheraton bar
area
and uh
i just felt a wave of depression i
probably did that gig yeah oh yeah well
east brunswick new jersey uh what did
you start with here i started march in
92. okay yeah so you might have it was
right around that time well i started up
in massachusetts and then i work i got
down to new york uh
i probably did my first road gig out
there end of 95 beginning in 96.
but i remember going out to those some
of those jersey ones in those hotels
awful yeah they were either great or you
just were driving home [ __ ] that's
you know thousand yard stare like oh my
god what have i done i remember doing
one with vinnie brand and bob levy where
there was a pool i believe in between us
and the audience i'll never forget that
gig we were on one side it was a holiday
inn and it was in the pool area and we
were it was which is an obvious place
for a comedy
yeah it was really bad i remember vinnie
or we were in the front but i remember
there was a pool
i think between us and the crowd but in
that arbitrage room i was i was
nobody was laughing in the back
and then i realized like oh they can't
hear
what is being said right repeat what
they say hey it buys you another couple
seconds and nobody knows you're doing it
isn't that weird like how with the
audience we know we're like you know
someone's like you know you you suck
you're terrible i suck and i'm terrible
it's like you've just bought yourself
yeah and if you hit this right
priceless time yeah yeah it's really
weird do you i don't know how to explain
this to people when when people how did
you come up with that that fan like i
don't know
when you see a funny moment i don't mean
a written joke but if someone slams you
and you're great at [ __ ]
firing back immediately
like donald hammond said he sees
impressions as colors like a yellow or
an orange he can't explain it
when i see like slamming something as
like it's like these weird choices
you're making they're kind of floating
in front of you like you don't see the
words
is that why yourself because you got the
fastest mind of anybody when you just
sit at the table at the cellar
dude when you is patrice was like she
would just make you [ __ ] yeah you'd
start crying when he was the best but
like as far as speed
like i thought patrice a lot of times he
would use his laugh to drown you out
like he had all these different things
you would just sit there
i remember when you started look at me i
was like oh [ __ ] he's looking at me he's
looking it was a different thing like
with keith i felt keith robinson
keith you could get you could get a
mittens face
to try to throw him off like keith stop
looking at me blah blah and that would
make him forget what he was going to say
but you never forgot
and vos all you had to do with i had
techniques for all you guys to survive
the pun vos all you had to do was lay on
the ropes and eventually he would say
something that bombed and then it would
come back on him he always got bit he
would hit you one two three times and
then that fourth or fifth one would be
so bad it bombed that everyone would
then jump on him so you you never really
had to get him back voss voss would be
pounding you and pounding you but he
always got greedy and threw a right-hand
lead
you always punch himself out always
punch himself out but how do you see
when you when you're
whether it's a heckler whatever how do
you
i can't explain to people how that works
like how how do you think of a joke or a
funny thing to say
it's almost like
like watching things float in front of
you and you grabbing them i look at it
more like
in the beginning
it was like remember like i have to have
these stock lines right hey wade you
learn how to whisper
yeah helicopter factory like what is
that they're already on it didn't even
it didn't even make sense
and it always got a laugh
um
but it was more like those i had those
stock lines and then it became i was
watching greg fitzsimmons and i've told
him this before on his show i learned
from greg
where greg would just ask him like greg
is [ __ ] unbelievable
on he's so good at [ __ ] with people
in the crowd i mean one time we were
playing this place the the grill 93
and uh oh my god where was it it was up
was on route 93 massachusetts yeah it
was not arlington that was where dane
was from springfield i can't remember
with an a i don't remember
and um andover mass andover there you go
yeah the girl 93 in andover mass and
these two guys showed up
with matching american flag shirts
and they sat in the front row
and greg was so good at trashing people
like i was either hosting or featuring
but me and the host or me in the feature
both said to greg greg we're not gonna
[ __ ] with those guys but you have to
promise us that you're gonna write at
the beginning go after him and he goes
absolutely absolutely so we deliberately
did not no these guys wanted to get
picked on and greg ended up going up
there
and he just started telling this story
that just went all the way around the
[ __ ] bend to the point people like
what is he talking about somehow he
brought around to be you know i mean
that would be like i don't know like
wearing matching american flags shirts
with your friends or something and then
he just pointed at the guys and opened
his mouth like david lee roth you know
when he looks at the back row and it
just [ __ ] absolutely
destroyed i saw one time at the cow loon
he [ __ ]
he by that it was like hannibal lecter
[ __ ] he could tell by the shoes the guy
was wearing he guessed the guy's name
and four guesses he guessed his job
the table the guy was sitting at was
going nuts and it was just all and of
course his name was horrible his job was
horrible where he lived was horrible he
thought he did a little vignette of
their family like he's unbelievable
at doing stuff like that so i so that's
funny when people ask me you know who
are your influences blah blah you know
as much as it was the greats that you
listen to people don't understand that
not only did you learn you know i was
watching to tell ck and all those guys
who were beyond me but i learned
watching guys that were uh you know
breaking in at the same time i did sure
yeah were you starting to because i a
lot of times you would you were you
would get yourself into the same
situation that a more seasoned guy
wouldn't and i would watch you get out
of it and be like oh that's i never
thought to do it that way right that's
how you skip that's how you take it and
stop it before it goes off the cliff in
the hole because i i realized too that a
lot of times i would lose crowds by
hitting too hard like you know a guy
throws up something that deserves a four
it's almost like you go right to i hope
you get aids yeah right to him yeah like
what's that what's that your [ __ ]
wife's got cancer like what dude but
there's totally unnecessary
like
it was in the crowd hates you for it so
it's like the worst is when someone's
heckling you in the front i'll never
forget this guy heckling me at rascals i
was a new comic but even back then i
knew this guy was being a [ __ ] because
he was he was heckling me and it wasn't
horrible [ __ ] that he was saying but it
was his eyes like i knew he's the
[ __ ] that scumbag in the office who's
resentful that he's not up here getting
laughs okay yeah yeah and the audience
can't see it so i was pounding him and i
really ruined his night and uh the crowd
hated me for it because they couldn't
see what a dicky was but you know how
like you know you just know yeah of
course i do and you can always tell like
a zillion times i'll never never regret
doing it though it's like that's 25
years ago it's been my first year of
comedy and i still feel good that i
wrecked that piece of [ __ ] tonight
because i knew he was coming out you
know i saw i remember i was at the punch
line in atlanta i had a guy like that
and all i can remember about what he
looked like was he had loafers with no
socks and he had fat feet so there was
like the
bulging out the front and he kept
putting his feet on the stage
so i made the joke to take him you know
to take him off or whatever and
it's you know because he really you know
had
and he just was [ __ ] annoying me and
it was just the fact that he kept
putting him back i knew that it wasn't
oh i'm sorry i just need to stretch my
legs out there was some sort of power
things going you're breathing into the
mic it was like a power thank you
[Music]
there was like this power thing going on
with them and it literally escalated to
the point that they had to kick him out
and he when he stood up he made sure he
got on the stage and took like half a
step towards me and he was just you know
this little [ __ ]
i don't know he probably was doing well
in business and he was used to people
telling not you know telling other
people what to do and uh but whatever
here we are now we're sitting here
talking about the process uh i want to
make sure that i get to the whole reason
why is a fancy man like yourself
out here in uh in los angeles do you got
you you you're working on something
what's going on well my
thanks bill
my advice show is uh coming on and uh
you know i just had to come out and plug
it it's hard to plug no it isn't that's
great dude what tell me about the show
i'm happy about it to do it like it's
it's an interview so i talk to
you know i do a monologue i mean i feel
ashamed whenever i explain things why
but i don't know it's that whatever
makes me a comic because that's that
[ __ ] right right shameful comment
colin described it as shame as finally
um
it's hosting a talk show and that's i
always wanted to do it so i hosted uh i
did four episodes and a monologue a
sketch you're hosting a talk show yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] great yeah i'm happy
man it's uh my first guests are are were
tyson and dana white together and it was
awesome it was like a really good
interview and i was like wow man that
went well i've never seen i mean this in
a good way i've never seen him give a
guy like you
a talk show they don't that's great yeah
because usually it's you know they're
usually telling you know if you're doing
a talk show hey jim kind of tone it down
a little so what what uh what channel is
it on it's on vice.com it's you know
it's uh it's online which is kind of
where i wanted it
and now can you curse and stuff whatever
you want total content freedom oh my god
content freedom um but bailey j is my
co-host um and she's kind of like my
announcer you know bailey yeah lovely
girl and uh you know so i think it's i
think it turned out bobby's suggestion
it's like dude you got to get bailey
involved and i think it's
i think oh bailey j the uh yeah yeah
okay okay what the [ __ ] was i thinking
of
i interviewed uh you know i interviewed
freeway rick you know who that the the
drug dealer the ex-drug dealer
oh that's us that sounds like a 70s
black guy nickname it is
it is he did 20 years
yeah he did and he was a big deal in the
80s he was like with the iran contra
uh scandal like he was buying
the guy he was getting his drugs from
was it was funneling money to the
contras and then uh you know rick went
to jail for he had life without parole
but he's out now on a technicality
because they was like a three strikes
thing or whatever but they charged them
twice so who optioned the rights for
this [ __ ] great movie
somebody's got to own them no one
michael k williams is playing him in
something in in a there's a the reporter
who broke his story
is being played by jeremy renner and i
think the reporter committed suicide
because people laughed at him the whole
iran contra thing and the drug
connection and the cia put money in the
black neighborhoods we had t.i wait a
minute they laughed at him so the
reporters back then they didn't think he
was right like i think when he was
talking about the government the cia
allowing drugs into these ghettos how
bad did they laugh and he must have been
getting [ __ ] yeah he probably
expected a pulitzer they were like were
they hanging him from his press undies
every day from the typewriter
they keep picking on me man i can't take
it i'm sweating there's a connection
they're letting the drugs come in i
[ __ ] feel it yeah and then he wound
up blowing his brains up but being
proven right we thought t.i was ti was
on a week before i interviewed rick ross
and we were like that sounded kind of
paranoid those are great guests uh well
the t.i was on open anthony not on uh
whatever but he was talking about the
the the drugs written up black diapers
like i don't know it sounded a little
bit conspiracy and then rick ross said
the same thing i'm like [ __ ] minty i was
right like i've heard it from too many
different sources that cia apologized it
was really interesting so he was a good
interview and then i did a couple of uh
comedians and uh you know hopefully he
will do more no dude you gotta when's
when's this coming out this wednesday
july 23rd
and
how does i can't say what time like i
guess when are they going to upload it i
don't know i'll just twitter it i'm not
sure that you know it's like they i
don't know how this one works like i'm
used to doing
promotion for stuff like i know exactly
what day it's on i know exactly what
time it's on right the first episode is
being released in two parts because it's
uh you know it's like a 45 minute
interview plus 20 other minutes of
content so it's like one day and then
the next day and they can watch the
whole thing
you know that sounds like a great great
guess
and then you know sidekick nobody has
anybody like bailey j that's great and
then usually a guy like you doesn't get
you guys they usually you're usually the
guy
the way they're like all right you know
just tone it down tone it down so let's
see a real i can't say i don't want to
insult anybody but like
somebody my taste
actually going out doing a monologue and
that type of stuff that you're gonna
pick on that's [ __ ] awesome man it
felt so nice to not have to tone it down
because in one of the episodes i just
did a bunch of sterling stuff which i've
been doing on stage but how long is that
going to be you know good right
and um he was a fun one
oh god i hope he lives forever i hope
with my angle on it still because my
special's coming out and i and i was
able to turn
that into some like i'm hoping i i the
point that i'm making uh
is still relevant is there anything
worse than when you shoot something
and it winds up something happens in the
meantime which dates
the reference or the bats yeah no but it
happens because this is i think
sometimes i i try not to overthink that
thing where you know if even a guy like
richard pryor talked about the
heavyweights of his time because you
know there's some comics are like you
know don't
do anything wear anything that's going
to make you look [ __ ] you know in
three years
like the cutting edge fashion like take
a like sinbad
like some of the stuff that that guy
wore you know what i mean like some of
that just in general some of this [ __ ]
from the early 90s late 80s early 90s
was pretty out there
so some people try to go just wear black
on black very kind of simple thing and
and then don't do anything topical
because it's going to date your special
it's like who gives a [ __ ] who cares
yeah i know if it's a great joke
it's a great joke like uh that prior one
i forget he's talking about the old
retired black fighter who was refereeing
in the ref uh one of the fighters
beating the [ __ ] out of a white guy and
he didn't he was joking that the guy
wouldn't stop it oh [ __ ] he looks okay
or whatever and that's still funny yeah
it's still [ __ ] funny so i think if
the joke is there
it let's see i'm trying to convince
myself what did pryor say and it's it
was a jerry quarry joke
right about it was something about how
he just he just loves black people
beating him up and it made me laugh so
hard and it was 40 years after he said
it it doesn't matter woody allen's stuff
he does references from the early 60s
it's hilarious yeah carlin opens one of
the specials you know the reagan people
i don't care i learned who jerry quarry
was
through richard pryor i didn't know who
james brown was until eddie murphy did
the bit all right i i was that [ __ ]
white like the world i was living in and
and people be like how the [ __ ] did that
how did how did you not know who he was
and was like well my parents were that
[ __ ] white and then there was three
channels
you know right and there was no internet
and it was like
you know i i i knew who the [ __ ]
jeffersons were i mean that was like the
only thing that was on tv it seemed like
good times but as far as stuff like that
was really difficult for a guy like him
even when he became an icon you know i
just saw recently he did like the mike
douglas show he did some shows but i was
a little kid so i i just didn't see him
so i remember laughing at the eddie i
told charlie this story and he was
beside himself
he was almost offended he goes get the
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] that
you knew who he was your parents knew
who he was i'm like i didn't i didn't
know who arguably the greatest performer
of the last century was
um do you see james brown and pavarotti
they did us they did it's a man's world
together how awesome it was unbelievable
unbelievable they really liked each
other that was a really i love stuff
like that yeah when they like to me that
that's a mash up like i don't like when
they just take two songs out of the same
tempo when it's supposed to blow my
[ __ ] mind it's like
yeah well if you get two songs at the
same speed you drop some [ __ ] out and
you throw some [ __ ] in right
not that i could ever figure out how to
do it no i couldn't there's a genius to
it but i still resent it the same i
understand hating it like i respect it's
hard to do it [ __ ] stinks
all right everybody here's the
advertising for this week i apologize
for the bad edit i just interviewed jim
on like friday or something when he was
in town
and you know we just
did it straight through without the
advertising because i didn't have it yet
so now i'm in my house
it's like 7 30 monday morning and my
wife is still sleeping so i gotta uh
i gotta read in this creepy voice so you
have to [ __ ] deal with it all right
you just [ __ ] deal with it this is
gonna be my voice
dollar shave club everybody the big
razor companies think we're stupid every
year they roll out some ridiculous
shaving technology gimmick and expect us
to flip out and shell out big bucks for
it do you really need a razor with a
vibrating handle or a roller pivot ball
back scratcher egg timer laser pointer
corkscrew you get the point okay you
don't need it
all right
we were all just shaving fine before any
of that crap and i personally definitely
don't need to spend my hat earned cash
on it
um if you're sick of being treated like
a [ __ ] join the hundreds of hundreds of
thousands of smarter people who joined
the dollarshaveclub.com
revolution dollar shave club delivers
the best blades and grooming supplies
for just a few bucks a month their
blades are better than the big shave
companies for a fraction of the price
and my listeners can get started now at
dollarshaveclub.com
and hey if you're already a member
remember you got to go check out dr
covey's
post shave lotion
it's the perfect way to make peace with
your face after the disruptive act of
shaving stop getting ripped off by the
big shave companies join
dollarshaveclub.com
burr that's dollarshaveclub.com
alright the next one stamps.com quick
convenient and most importantly easy to
use that's how i would describe
stamps.com it will make your mailing and
shipping an absolute breeze with
stamps.com you can buy and print
official us postage using your computer
and your printer there's nothing to
learn
that's why i like it because i'm an
idiot stamps.com will give you a digital
scale it autumn it automatically
calculates exact postage for any letter
any package they'll even help you choose
the best class of mail to get your mail
there on time for the least amount of
money then drop your mail into any
mailbox or hand it to your mailman and
that's it you're done you'll never have
to go to the post office again trust me
mailing and shipping has never been
easier i use stamps.com to send out all
my posters my t-shirts dvds whatever the
hell i'm selling at the end of the week
and if i can figure it out so can you
right now use my last name bur b-u-r-r
for this special offer no risk trial
plus a hundred and ten dollar bonus
offer that includes a digital scale and
up to fifty five dollars free postage
don't wait go to stamps dot com right
now before you do anything else click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in bur burr that stamps
dot com enter bur
all right last one last one here we go
legal zoom everyone most americans don't
have a will
but why is that you don't want the court
dictating what happens to your property
and your minor children do you of course
you don't so why procrastinate most
people say well it's too expensive or
it's too time consuming blah blah blah
blah i got an answer for you
legalzoom.com too expensive legal zoom
prices just make sense too time
consuming it just takes 20 minutes and
legal zoom can guide you through from
start to finish the service was
developed by some of the best legal
minds in the country and they make it
painless for you to get the legal help
you need in fact helping people get
legally protected has been their mission
for the past 13 years during the
national make a will month get special
pricings on wills and living trusts by
entering bur burr and the referral box
at checkout again that discount code is
burr b-u-r-r god forbid something
happens to you but do you really want to
add to the pain
as they're dragging the swing set out of
the backyard and giving it to somebody
else down the street some bankers kid
right
i know that was a weird example but
somewhere in there that made sense
anyways it's national make a will month
so don't wait protect your family
protect your future at legalzoom.com
today legalzoom was developed by top
attorneys to provide self-help services
at your specific direction but they are
not a law firm legal help is furnished
through uh vetted independent attorneys
legalzoom.com discount code burr b-u-r-r
did you ever try an instrument when
you're growing up no i didn't i'm not
musical i used to draw i wanted to be an
artist i would draw like i was obsessed
with kiss or draw pictures of kiss i
could never draw hands
that's always the thing my hands were
terrible so every count don't you just
do the three-fingered thing no i put the
hands behind the back i really would
everyone had hands behind the back i
couldn't i could not grasp that's that's
what makes an artist if you can draw
hands you could probably draw anything
in the world hands in them
try drawing someone's hand it's [ __ ]
hard i think the face is hard yeah it
can be but i can i could work out a face
i could do i would it would be a little
off you know what i mean like it was it
was like rocky dennis-ish sometimes but
at least it was a face little bell palsy
yeah yeah that was all right i always
when i when i tried drawing i just
remember everybody was always jacked
whoever i'd like the one body type i
could draw would be like [ __ ] jacked
and everybody had the same goddamn nose
but uh
i don't know there's actually a show out
here that i'm doing coming up
where uh there's a live band and it's
you know i want to do the show it's
[ __ ] cool where it's like you go out
and you just sort of riff about music
and that type of thing and then when uh
when when you're done with your set
you then go and jam with the band
however you want to do it you can sing a
song and they'll learn the song
beforehand
or whatever instrument you play that
your idea is no no no this is uh
somebody else's idea i hope i didn't say
that and everybody's going to steal the
idea but it's [ __ ]
i'm
going gonna be doing it coming up man
it's gonna be fun as [ __ ] though well
you have balls to do that that would
scare me uh yeah but what i've learned
is i don't mean yeah like i got balls
what i've learned is that there comes a
point when you get something
down anywhere in life
you got your gig down if you don't keep
learning you don't keep pushing yourself
to try to be like all right whatever i'm
doing how do i get better at this i
always equate it to like i don't know
basketball of some reason i don't
[ __ ] play it but like you know he
always goes to his right then you gotta
learn to go to your left he sucks on
defense i gotta get better at defense
it's like the whole thing like i read
this whole
this great magazine out about jordan how
he just kept working and working and
working and working and working and in
like
you can literally read the article
and not be a jordan but just apply that
right and work and work and work and
work so for me
um
i'm really comfortable being a stand-up
but i'm not comfortable playing drums
necessarily
out in public or whatever so over the
years when every time i get a chance to
sit in i would sit in and just go
through
you know it's just like you go back to
being an open mic i think there's like
an ego thing that's involved that once
you're good at something and people know
you're good
you're you're embarrassed to kind of
stink at something a little bit sure so
you're like oh i don't want to do that i
don't it takes like i don't know
this it's a balance of the balls to try
it and then also still be [ __ ] around
to be like listen guys i know i'm not a
professional drummer or whatever so we
can handle bombing on something like
that because it's comics you kind of
learn all right like i know how to be
funny if i'm sucking at something or i
know how to own it right like if you own
something so completely people kind of
like all right well what are you gonna
right now he's owning that he's not a
good drummer or singer so yeah
if you go out yeah if you go out there
and you just you're acting like a
[ __ ] idiot you're having a good time
then they don't have to worry like
like i just don't want the crowd at any
moment to have that thing like oh wait
is he like serious here does he like
feel like he should be in a band i don't
okay for anything
for anybody concerned
i do not you're a good actor though man
you're a really good actor i i finally i
finally went through breaking bad and we
interviewed everyone on that show and
i'd never seen it we had cranston we had
[ __ ] uh the guy quite hank we had the
the skyler everyone and then i finally
watched it and you're so good it you
didn't take me out of it like and i know
you so well and whenever you see like a
close friend in something
and man i was like [ __ ] that's bill and
then right into the character it was
really [ __ ] awesome i didn't think
i'd seen you since i finally watched
breaking bad i i'll i'm learning to take
compliments but i will say
that show the way it was done all you
had to do is memorize what they say and
hit your marks and they handled the rest
dude they just
it was uh
i don't know how to equate it pick a
great [ __ ] sports team and you're
coming off the bench it's like somehow
you're going to end up wearing a ring
you know right right right yeah be one
of those guys that awful white guy
dancing that shaq used to make fun of
whenever the lakers would win it like
that's who i was
who i was on breaking bad but it was uh
it was fun and um
you know what are you most nervous doing
were you because i remember the first
time i saw you with cranston uh you i
think were you in a car
no the first time i i had a scene with
him i was so excited because uh dude i
was a fan of that show from the very
beginning okay from the pilot episode
so i was so invested
in the show
and and couldn't wait for the next
season so to all of a sudden
be on it interacting with these [ __ ]
characters it was it was like
you got sucked into your tv and then
fast forwarded into time right so there
was this
it would i i always said i felt like i
won a radio contest or something like
you know do you want to play a storm
trooper or the next
star wars and stand next to darth vader
i always felt that when i was there and
i would have been happy just getting one
of them
and the fact that they kept bringing me
back and the fact that you know uh vince
gilligan used so many stand-up comics to
get back to your thing when when uh the
question
the first scene i did with cranston
was uh
was after i'm trying not to to ruin it
for anybody because everybody you know
oh people i've seen it right right you
know spoiler alert when does that run
out you know i know but um
we'd shaken down this guy from money and
he got hurt so we had to go talk to the
lawyer saul goodman so was me and
lavelle crawford but that was he played
hugh i didn't realize that was the level
crawford i know he was [ __ ] unreal
yes he was good i didn't realize he's a
comedian too that's right so we had this
little bit that we were doing at the top
this whole act of god thing and then
brian cranston character bursts in so
our thing was we jump up and sort of
make sure that he's not coming for saul
and then saul tells us to screw and i
was so
excited
that i was actually going to be in a
scene sure with mr white because mr
white to me it took everybody i don't
know how long like 3-4 season for the
entire country but for die-hards like
myself like
he was
you know
i've never had a guy like a character
that followed that i was rooting
for so hard and then all of a sudden he
took this [ __ ] turn
he took this turn where i'm like i kind
of felt weird about rooting for him and
then i was just started watching going
like dude what are you doing
just turn yourself in just stop
and it was it was like literally
watching literally watching like someone
you loved like you knew like a family
member rooting him on and being making
excuses for him yeah what's he supposed
to do the guy he's sick he's not giving
him any [ __ ] he put his time in you know
that type of [ __ ] and then somewhere you
know
it you know i don't know after how many
[ __ ] murders
and just some of the [ __ ] that he
started doing to jesse that it started
to it started to turn and it was
it just was unreal to be you know i've
lucked out i've really knocked out where
i've gotten to be a part very small part
of some
some pretty amazing things because my
imdb page is is a pretty quick read but
um
i got to tell you i like i've always
liked the [ __ ] you've done that's the
stuff you did in uh
spider-man i wish i wish i could have
seen that whole [ __ ] rant you did
even though i just you know i don't like
him and he stinks but you you were
really in it and they had you in the
back of that truck
you just looked like this new york guy
who was dropping off something
and you were [ __ ] pissed i know
you're going to [ __ ] on your acting but
i loved it no no no but i'm going to
point out this is why bill's a good
friend and this is why i love bill
because honestly you you had a part in
what is tremendo
it's one of the culturally biggest
events how bad would keith be trashing
us right now
but would be nice for friends
keith doesn't know how to be nice about
anything oh but remind me about keith
and he came in with that [ __ ] p he
came with a dave chappelle shirt uh the
other night from
oh no he's wearing a chappelle at uh
radio city and me and colin are at the
table
and we're like oh you [ __ ] fat fanboy
and we just attacked him and he sat down
for five minutes and he goes i'm going
to change the shirt and he got up and he
left the comedy cellar and he came back
with a button-down shirt over and that's
the second time in my life i've been
able to chase him out i remember one
time he ran out with this i was there
that night i forget what he ran out that
puffy white awful look like it looked
like uh
like a bedding shirt that he had on and
i beat him so terrible
he hung in there for like two rounds
three rounds and then it was just and
then he stood up and ran out and i
remember being pissed being like you can
[ __ ] do that i didn't know you could
leave i never thought to leave like that
pounding i took
the bus pounding which is one of the
all-time class you guys literally did a
headlining set you did 45 minutes
on me when i was gonna do uh
oh [ __ ] that was that that was it we
were both gonna do it
no no sd
yeah sd whatever the [ __ ] it was sd
somebody approached the comedy seller
these atlanta brave fans and they said
it was nine backs or no no it was the
braves
and they said you know they were taking
a bus from manhattan up to yankee
stadium and they wanted to hire comic
for the bus ride up and at the end of it
they were going to give you a world
series ticket so we sat there going uh
man that's going to be brutal i don't
know
all of that type of [ __ ]
and um
i forget what happened at the last
without me knowing
you said you know what i'm not [ __ ]
doing that that's [ __ ] right and i
didn't know it so i agreed to do it
and then
we sat down and we started trashing each
other and this is this is what you
started it i [ __ ] go totally remember
i said this to you i made fun of your
shirt but blah blah and i was getting
you and everyone was laughing and you
know that thing at the table you're like
oh my god i'm winning i'm winning i'm
finally winning here and then as they're
all laughing you just lean in you go
whatever
bus boy and the whole table stopped and
went what
and you said bill burr is going to do
stand-up on a bus on the way the route
and all [ __ ] chairs turned at me
that's the funny and dude all the
killers were there you patrice voss
kevin hart kevin hart was there keith
was there
45 minutes
i didn't say a word and just got pounded
and then and i was still gonna do the
gig because to me that was an easy gig
sure all i had to do was [ __ ] on the
yankees the whole way make fun of
[ __ ] new york and say that atlanta
was better
say that i was a red sox fan i would
have been [ __ ] shotgun and beers with
them it would have been a joke but i
ended up not doing the gig which a lot
of people don't know i didn't do the gig
because patrice in the end of it
dude you guys were trashing me so bad
like
strangers were either laughing or they
were going oh
i'm trying to think of some of the great
ones patrice imitating me
oh patrice goes hey when they call you
out on stage he goes are you going to
come out of the bathroom are you going
to walk up those little steps
i remember all of them he had another
one where he was he was imitating me at
the end of the show this is a visual so
i have to explain it i finished i'm in
the front front of the bus i go hey
thanks a lot you guys are great and then
he imitates me turning around sitting
down and then as people are walking by
reaching over my show good show good job
go hey thanks a lot thanks a lot thanks
a lot reaching over my shoulder
uh they asked you guys asked if i was
going to use the
the bus driver's microphone to do the
show if i was going to bring my own dude
every joke was just funnier than the
next one and it was never ending i took
this [ __ ] brutal pony but i was still
gonna do it
i was like [ __ ] these guys i'm a sports
fan i want to go to the game i don't
give a [ __ ]
so in the end you guys had all left and
it was just me and patrice sitting there
and he just goes bill
he goes
you're making enough money at this point
if you want
if you want to go to the game buy a
[ __ ] ticket all right
he goes dude i will he called me the
n-word he said and what he goes i will
stand in front of that bus
so you don't do that gig do not do that
[ __ ] gig and it was the first time i
ever thought of like you know like
self-esteem yeah like why not just blow
the cash and actually have a little
dignity because you just come into this
business doing like those jersey
turnpike things and all that [ __ ] that
you don't you just feel like i need to
learn how to do this so i didn't do the
gig
and i actually passed the gig off to
somebody else and i had taken such a bad
pounding i said listen i'll never tell
anybody
i'll never tell anybody who i gave this
gig to and i think the person who did it
didn't they come in and say who it was
i believe that i'll tell you when we're
done because i mean it doesn't matter no
no it's funny it doesn't matter now but
i i i don't think he would care no i
passed it on not at all no i don't feel
bad that's it many many years ago and
he'd probably love to be so i asked him
what it was like and he he told me later
i go what was it like he goes oh dude he
goes it was brutal yeah it was brutally
goes but the second was over and i had
that world series ticket dude he ran
away from those people and it's
hilarious it was their ticket so then
you just sort of sat next to them so he
kind of couldn't leave him but uh
i'll never forget that that was that was
another turning point that i learned
from someone who's i started with was to
have self-esteem
like at some point you can't say no
like i'm not you know what
i'm making enough money here in the city
it was i was making great money but i
was making enough money that if i wanted
to blow i mean how much was this world
series taking four or five hundred bucks
back there
to sit in the upper deck
to not stand on a bus you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and humiliate yourself
so you know what those gigs teach you to
like like the seller
is getting pounded so terribly like i
get beaten so badly sometimes you know
bobby or keith and colin and you know
when they're all attacking you there's
times where i'm i'm a comedian for over
20 years and i find myself still
answering seriously like when they're
killing me i'm like well no that's not
exactly what happened like i'm getting
beaten up so bad i know i'm helpless i'm
[ __ ] i'm turning into like my
girlfriend when i'm annoyed like you
know that's not accurate at all it's so
it's cleansing though to get a beating
like that it's it's like you know one of
my favorite ones watching you taking a
beating was that time when you were on a
date
and patrice was yelling over at you and
you weren't talking back to him and he
started and you you just started opening
for dice and you were thrilled your hero
and you guys were hanging out and
patrice started imitating dice talking
to you in the character during the day
and you were sitting in the corner
trying to ignore him and patrice was all
the way across the restaurant and he's
going hey jim let's go to the mall
and we were all [ __ ]
crying laughing
and you finally had to give in to it man
like those are the things
what i loved about it and like i love
watching your date kind of keep hearing
the name jim and hearing us laughing and
slowly figuring out like is he talking
about you and you trying to stay in the
date yeah for an excruciating
five minutes dude
[ __ ] i miss that guy man i i remember
one time i was uh i would i would always
come in off the road and not sleep i
would be done with usually dice on
saturday night so sunday morning i'd fly
home with no sleep and i wasn't doing
radio and at that time so sunday nights
i'd be
loopy and go on at the cellar on no
sleep and i always had good sets because
i'd be creative because i'd be over
tired
and i would come here we played chess
every night there i would play with
keith i remember you were good too man
i start a little circle yeah but i mean
compared to a real chess player i'm a
[ __ ] i'm a chimp but i mean you know
in our little the knee you bob yeah you
were like reading the bobby fischer book
you were into it dude yeah yeah i do
enjoy him um
he's quite a character i was getting i
remember i was because keith was such a
[ __ ] talker like he's like he's like one
of those [ __ ] bums in the park like
they're like master level players
because they're all homeless and they
play for drinks and they play for food
so they're real players
but keith you know you move your queen
you do that stupid thing with his
fingers like he was sprinkling salt like
he's sprinkling salty pick up ah let's
see what color panning she did and i
would like literally be non-comedian guy
quit touching my [ __ ] piece man
and uh you gotta you gotta re-explain
that to the listeners keith what keith
robinson would do when he knew he was
closing in on your queen he would reach
over and pick it up and be like yeah
what color panties is she wearing and
set it down like he's just touching you
talking oh yeah i was annoying as [ __ ] i
remember one time patrice pulled my
chair out after i had lost i had lost
and i was so [ __ ] over tired and
cranky and uh he wanted to play keith so
he had winners and i lost and he was
just such a dismissive pull my chair out
he moved me
with you still sitting in it i was of
course i was
and he dragged me out and i was so mad i
went don't touch my chair like i'm
[ __ ] a grown man and that's my
comeback
don't touch my chair like oh and how
long did you get pounded for that it was
just an awful night and that was a bad
night i was overtired i sucked and yeah
you know was the worst was the carryover
the carryover trashing where there was
so much meat left over on the bone you'd
come back the next night hey the [ __ ]
chair guys you sit down dude don't touch
his chair like
sometimes i think about those days and i
was just like
it's it's [ __ ] hilarious and it's a
goddamn tragedy that we never sat down
and wrote anything all we we took all of
our comedic skills and just used them to
humiliate each other yeah we just sat
there but
it all worked out doesn't it it
those moments
i think made every one of us
a better comic a thicker skinned comic
because then you're on stage in front of
10 000 people and getting an unfair
booing that was when we first started on
k rock right and you had been not the xm
listeners loved you but they the k rock
listeners didn't know you as well at
that point because it was a new thing
and you had been away
and they're booing you and you pull out
this [ __ ] one of the great
moments of stand up that i've ever
witnessed which was
just turning ten thousand philadelphia
[ __ ] monsters and they're the worst
crowds in the world if they don't like
you and you turned them you did the
impossible and that's that's like
well i lucked out the sports thing there
was enough
jersey and new york sports fans you know
the patrick division and uh whatever the
ml the national league east or whatever
there's enough mets fans that hated the
phillies there's enough [ __ ]
fans everybody hates the [ __ ] flyers
you know except for philly fans so i was
able to do that what was funny was i
actually when i finished
that set
i felt bad because you had to go on next
and i was like oh god you know when a
comic burns down the room and that was
basically that was not a like you can
burn down the room i feel is the
headliner
but to burn down the room when there's
another guy going up on basically your
showcase night i was sitting there i
thought you were going to be mad at me
and i was and you went out
never addressed
what just happened went right into your
act and [ __ ] smashed them
yeah i mean again they knew me though it
was like the the the terrestrial crowd
knew me so i had that you know it's kind
of like
you know they were expecting me to come
out but i i felt uh you know that if
that show occurred six months after that
right when that crowd knew you that
never would have happened
that was just that was a really weird
transition time but what you did with
that crowd i mean yeah it was the sports
knowledge but it was about
uh the ability to pull that out in front
of all those people because it took a
while they didn't just start well you
know what i had been booed before a
couple i've got booed uh
on a vegas show i and and i didn't leave
but i didn't know the first time you get
boo dude it's [ __ ] unreal it's like
it's the weirdest experience because you
have exactly what you want the
total focus of the crowd but the exact
opposite emotion right i've always
compared it to like you know when they
do the reverse echoes on those zeppelin
things to make it seem like you're in
hell like the echo comes first before
your voice that's like sort of the
stand-up version of that where it's like
they're cheering but they're booing it's
the most [ __ ] up thing and
and i remember after getting booed um
just [ __ ] walking through the hotel
going back to my inst and i started
thinking about people in the crowd
and it's like all right bill you got boo
but you let that guy boo you
you let that woman with that awful dress
that guy with the big head you could at
least said that it was just so shocking
the first time it happened and also i uh
you know i did a lot of those uh the
uptown rooms that they called them the
black black crowd yeah so you kind of
had to get you know
i was in fight and shape so it's somehow
uh
i just remember opie coming through the
the curtain opie and and i think he had
his glass of red wine and opie just came
walking through and was just like he
said he goes that was one for the ages
bro and just came walking out what was
funny was you went out and killed and
the second that was done
that was the end of the show and then
they brought me back out for the curtain
call
and i got booed again
half clapping half booing
and i remember there was this dude
who ran up to the stage he was going
billboard he's screaming he's going [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] you and i'm going what and he's
he's giving me the finger
he's going [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and i kept
going what it's like you're giving me
the finger how do i not know i just kept
going i i can't you i literally got him
hopping mad he was jumping up and down
screaming giving me the finger i just
kept going i can't i kept cupping my ear
like i can't hear you and the guy [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you and it just i just laughed
at him and uh
that was yeah that was the end of it and
uh
i remember i i rode back with bobby
kelly
and um i had a [ __ ] splitting
headache after it and uh i just remember
riding back with bobby
and
and he was just laughing going dude do
you realize you just told
10 000 people to go [ __ ] themselves and
i was dreading it because i was like
[ __ ] i know somebody filmed that because
i thought when it got on
the internet
i knew comics would appreciate it but i
didn't know that i didn't know fans
would get it if they would just be like
oh you got booed you sucked
you know [ __ ] this guy haha everybody
laughing at you and [ __ ] because you
know can kind of go can kind of go
either way but whatever i i
we're here for you here no no no no that
to me was uh that was a fascinating
thing to watch because it was
legitimately funny stuff it wasn't like
you were obnoxious and got the crowd
like you were really
pounding them like a comic like that's
what was so fun about if you had just
taken your pants off and waved your [ __ ]
at them and
like all right any idiot could well
you're so [ __ ] hilarious though but
it would be that would have been much
better obviously but i mean
that would have been like instant legend
but the fact that you got them i i saw a
guy do that did you i'm not gonna say
because i don't want to get him in
trouble but i saw uh
when i was doing late nights at the
seller do you remember why they used to
have that water pipe they used to hang
sure just and this guy used to go up
he's a [ __ ] madman
and he used to [ __ ] hang from that
pipe by one arm and he had this crazy
look on his face he looked like charles
manson i'm trying to let you know who
this guy was right
so
he went on stage and he's doing his
[ __ ] thing and like really just one
of these great comics where like just
the pain of whatever he went through is
right there on the surface so if anybody
moves
he's gonna cut their head off so there
was some
woman who was all [ __ ] dressed up or
something sitting you know she's in her
50s and she's not laughing and he just
keeps looking at her and he just finally
just starts going like isn't that right
mom huh mom
mommy and he got in her face and he
finally just goes mom and screamed in
her face and she got like mad
and she goes uh she started giving him
[ __ ] and he said like lady if you got to
the point it's like lady if you don't
shut up i'm gonna take my dick out and
slap you in the face with it and she
goes you don't have the balls and he
goes oh i don't have the balls and he
starts unzipping his pants the crowd is
going [ __ ] nuts because they think
he's joking and he [ __ ] pulled his
dick out
pull his dick out
and he he had it by the shaft and just
his [ __ ] purple head is coming out
and he made these machine gun noises
like right in her face dude [ __ ]
place
went
ballistic
[ __ ] ballistic and he ended his set
there i hope so yeah and wanda
who was hosting at the time up and
coming wanda sykes i think she was the
host
[ __ ] outro and then brought me up was
it wanda
wanda hosted one of the [ __ ] up ones i
can't remember so brings me up
and i had to go on after him and i was
still new to new york and i was i was
already gonna bomb and he took his dick
out and shook it in this [ __ ] woman's
face and dude i can't even tell you how
hard
i ate it and i was too green
i didn't know to be like just riff about
the guy yeah
i went up and tried to do my act i went
up and i immediately went up and like
gee it's been raining a lot here in new
york city just it just completely
flatlines yeah it's like walking into a
party and not acknowledging what's just
been happening yeah that was awful yeah
yeah i think i know who you mean man
yeah there you go
well listen we're uh we're a little over
an hour dude i can't tell you how
excited i am thank you bill to to see it
and once again uh promoted it's going to
be this wednesday july 23rd is the
premiere episode with uh dana white and
mike tyson are my guests and uh i think
people will like it i'm actually really
happy with it which is rare dude i'm as
excited to see the monologue as i am
just to see a guy like you because i
always wondered i always wanted like you
know you ever be like doing a bit you're
just thinking that'd be a great
monologue joke because it's topical like
say you're you're you're clippers guy
stuff
you know which i haven't seen which i
know is going to be [ __ ] great but
like uh i can't imagine like
seeing that kind of thing rather than
just being like the safe right sort of
uh looks like there's going to be two
empty seats courtside come tonight and
the clippers right i mean some of the
some of the models is like are you even
[ __ ] trying um anyways that's the
special uh podcast here with jim norton
i'm glad i finally was able to get you
on this i appreciate it uh i'll see you
up in montreal when trying to drag my uh
hungover ass out of bed
and come down and do the uh
the now opium jimmy show yes oh yeah i'm
doing the keynote speech too so it
should be a real gentleman's affair oh
you are i know you're getting the the
award
uh this year for uh comic of the year
for hanging in there long enough to get
one man you've had a great year and it's
it's a deserved thing if i see a comic
where i don't like getting [ __ ] like
that i'm not just saying that because
you're my friend you're a great comic
and when you see a guy you admire you
know it's like
the thing is people like i don't suck
each other's dicks but it's like i don't
get to tell my friends like you know
what i mean like hey man i love what you
said you don't get to tell your friends
that we're just we're used to each other
all right i just like doing festivals
because i finally get to see you guys
because once we all start we all moved
up the same time yeah you know hosting
featuring right then headlining so you
never got to work on the road with each
other but when we were all doing spots
in the city you could kind of watch that
was another thing remember we used to go
downstairs when someone would be on
stage and you just stare at them kevin
hart yeah and try to take confidence and
kevin kevin didn't back down nope he
took it yeah and he was very new too
he we would walk down me you patrice
keith bobby whoever else was around just
sit in the cellar was half empty back
then and sit in the front rows ugh
and or laugh obnoxiously louder just
awful jokes when you see it i'm a little
in his little [ __ ]
what about when florentine would start
groans
those are the greatest skills of ever he
would sit in the back
he would sit in the back of the crowd
and he would turn the crowd on you by
like groaning he could almost like throw
his voice oh jesus oh come on oh yeah
come on and then like it was contagious
and then there'd be like three people ah
and
just get it going we ruined vosses night
one night of caroline's because the
curtain was drawing was a sunday night
jim's on one side of the curtain and i'm
on the other and just doing the there
was a groans in stereo like oh man and
there was florentine's we wanted to
conceptualize that and i'll never forget
boss for 45 minutes on stage just being
combative with you what the [ __ ] do you
guys want from me you know how [ __ ]
ornery he is [ __ ] dope so yeah why
did we do that to each other it's funny
why didn't we support i'm just we never
never support each other i remember voss
and patrice got into some huge fight
down in caroline's
because he he was actually opening for
patrice and patrice trashed his cd so
bad
he brought it up on stage and he ripped
it in half and i ripped the cover in
half and then broke it and
he was trashing it so bad and the crowd
laughed so hard that voss got mad for
real and it was one of the you know
we've had a zillion real arguments and
then two days later you don't give a
[ __ ] and it was just like why would you
do that me and patrice had a real
argument we were doing the colin
quinshaw on nbc i was trying to get
something through standards and
practices you know he was just being
patrice
he just gave me a hard time with this
woman
and i'm like [ __ ] dude shut up like
you know and we start i'm like you know
you know i know you're a comedian you
have to prove it i'm [ __ ] doing it
this is work you know i was trying to
get like literally a piece of material
through and we had like a real argument
over it and keith had to [ __ ] play
you know
the uh the arbiter oh yeah
dude i had a real [ __ ]
one that became a classic because of the
[ __ ] internet i had that huge one
with him
over this stupid [ __ ] mancow show
um on your show on the opie anthony show
we like patrice called up told his man
count thing trashed me
and then i called up monday to defend
myself and of course
somebody on the show
put [ __ ] patrice on hold he just put
the two dogs in the ring
you know i vaguely remember i don't even
know dude it was a [ __ ] like we were
pissed at each other for like you know
what it was funny but what broke the ice
i think was that uh was that philly rant
the philly rant we finally started
talking to each other we had talked in
like you know three four months which
wasn't hard because we weren't seeing
each other too much we were kind of just
pissed
and um
when if you watch the philly rant
there's a time where i look over the dj
going dude why are you yelling out [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] me up i vaguely remember
doing that but what actually was was
patrice was trying to help me he yelled
out invincible which would have been a
great one to bring up about philly which
was about a guy who was playing it was
working in a bar
tries out for the eagles not only does
he get a tryout he makes the [ __ ]
team and has an impact like i could have
just gone off on how bad the eagles
sucked um
and i i he you know he threw that out
there like got past our stupid acting
like a couple [ __ ] not talking to
each other saw me in trouble and [ __ ]
threw that out there and then when i
came off stage
he just started talking like you know
one of the few times he ever threw me a
compliment right um
and then you know then we were cool
after that it was just like a [ __ ] i
don't know
ah jesus christ whatever we got a lot of
stories at this point yeah it's nice
though i like it though i i like uh you
know like musicians i hear musicians
talk and but that must have been fun to
be a part of that but then i realized
like i'm a part of a pretty cool group
of people just comedians who i like and
it's like i never get to watch i don't
watch david tell i don't watch
you if you're on i don't want to watch
stand-ups did you see a tell's latest
special did you see it oh my god we
gotta watch it i love dave we were doing
co-headlining gigs and he would walk on
stage literally like a [ __ ] like a
gnome he's carrying a plastic bag with
things in them it's like he's losing his
mind and every once in a while because i
would always make him go on last and i'm
like look dude i'll take less money i
don't think that's the anti-social oh no
this was just me and dave doing it
okay and uh jesus what a [ __ ] show it
was a good show but then we would riff
at the end like i would come on stage
with him and we would just doing 15 to
20 minutes playing with the audience and
that was fun you were awesome with that
yeah we had a good time he's great
but watching him like even for the
couple of minutes when i came back he
would always throw out one or two that
would just make me [ __ ] hate being a
comedian like god i'll never he just did
one dumb line like you ever been on
mushrooms or
you're so high and you think you're
having a pillow fight but then you
realize you're holding a live baby
i'm like i just wish i thought of that
that's dude he had one i can't i don't
remember how we set it up but
the olympics were going on and somebody
doing the luge had died that day
and and he went on stage and said
something to the effect that i think i
think it's very fitting that the
olympics started with the sacrifices i
can't even do how we did it but he did
it you know when he talks like low and
he just sort of vaguely threw it out
there yeah and just to see if the crowd
even got it i was just like oh my god
that's so [ __ ] so such a smart joke
going back to the original olympics and
like that time when i don't know though
they had sex i don't even [ __ ] know
it's just yeah he's one of those he but
he's a guy that i will watch because
there's
there's him and harlan williams are two
guys the way they do their [ __ ] it's
just like
there's no way
i'm gonna
there's gonna be no overlap the way like
harlem just comes out hey what do you
say there pig in a blanket what are you
what are you doing there buddy what are
you doing their sport he just kind of
goes off on these crazy
i don't even know what he's doing
absolutely [ __ ] destroys that last
time i went to harlan
i said that to him i go nobody in your
career has ever walked up to you going
hey harlan i kind of have a kind of got
a joke like that you know
so anyways i got my dog downstairs so i
gotta i gotta go uh
thank you for go get it yeah man um um
you're so funny you're so used to doing
the [ __ ] show you said thank you for
coming oh actually i did come over to
your hotel room
okay
thank you for coming on the podcast i'm
glad we were able to uh
to finally
knock one of these out and uh like he
said uh wednesday july 23rd
what's the what's the website vice.com
it'll be easy to find vice.com check out
jim norton's new show called the jim
norton show the gym noah jesus that's
clever thanks bill all right go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll see you on monday
you